Switzerland used to be called helvetica  like the font it all started back in  like 58 BC when this guy Julius Caesar  conquered this part of Europe and  suddenly it was a part of the Roman  Empire and adopted a Latin name that was  named after the tribe the helveti tribe  if I'm pronouncing that right but did my  best okay but this isn't just ancient  history this is still what Switzerland  is kind of called today Swiss internet  domains are DOT CH and that stands for  confederation I can't say this  and that stands for confederation  helvetica the helvetic Confederacy my  website is johnnyharris.ch because I  love Switzerland now helvetica the font  it was originally called new house  grotesque not exactly the catchiest  prettiest sounding name so they decided  to rename it to helvetica after  Switzerland where it was developed and  I'm sure that the name change helped it  become one of the most loved fonts in  the world all because